let's talk about lies hate and slander
with Alexander Harbor from eco the
association of the internet industry now
you coordinate the Berlin office and you
have an actual complaints office there
what sort of complaints do you get on a
daily basis yeah
last year we received about 250,000
complaints quite different in more than
just one a day that's true and they have
a team about five lawyers in Cologne and
they're charging about the quality of
the complaints as illegal content or is
it just a complain about something you
don't like then it's not illegal and
then we can't delete it and we can't get
in contact with the police or something
like that so how tough is it drawing the
line between freedom of expression and
something that is actually slanderous
this question is really hard to answer
and one thing is for sure we need time
for that we need competence of our
employees to understand the context of
the complaints and the text which is
received by our website a cooperage data
we've calling that we need time and
competence because it's not easy to say
okay this is illegal or this is legal
but what is actually considered
slanderous these days because if you go
into something like TripAdvisor you're
trying to find out is this a good hotel
or not you've got such a wide array of
opinions and posts how do you I can't
even work out as a consumer what's right
and what's wrong
yeah that's the power of the user
nowadays in the Internet to church if
you like the hostel or the hotel or if
you didn't like it but for the company
it's obviously hard to argue them
against maybe something which was not
fair but it's not illegal if it's
something it's not fair then you need to
get in kind of reputation management and
to answer about facts that it may be
different than this user experience what
do companies actually need moderators so
to speak going through the channels and
and sifting out what's right wrong
what's true what's false I always would
say after a complaint
don't do that proactive to go to through
the internet and decide which is maybe
which content is offensive or maybe
illegal and the law is if you receive a
complaint as an internet service
provider then you have the duty to check
it okay but you need time for that you
need time to get money and money and
have a choice how much does it cost for
the corporation's there's a put back
depends on on the size of the
corporation of course for us as the
association of the internet we financed
five lawyers full-time there so you can
imagine what this cost and if you're a
bigger company and need much more person
of course it's a lot but I think it's
worth that's not the point that you need
to engage people who have the competence
and that's a point why I'm a bit nervous
when I see this algorithm doing the job
all the time because they're not not
able actually to see is this ironic this
context or they're just deleting it and
this may be another problem then we have
in the context of freedom of speech okay
Alex we'll get back to you in a moment
first of all I want to turn to Facebook
as you all probably know it's one of the
most valuable companies in the world and
it's all thanks to your data of course
the social network sells it and makes a
killing and you don't care all that much
about it because the service for you is
free it was once just a small student
project now it's a global corporation
around one quarter of the world's
population is a registered Facebook user
nearly two billion people post likes
comments and pictures they spend an
average of 42 minutes a day on Facebook
the company almost tripled its net
income over the past year reaching the
equivalent of nine billion euros the
company doesn't even charge fees so how
is that possible the answer Facebook
members pay with their data
every click makes the customers and
their interests more visible Facebook
then sells that information to other
companies
so that they can tailor their
advertising to each Facebook user this
is known as targeting for example those
who like cats get adverts for cat food
and not just any cat food for one of its
customers Facebook sorted cat lovers
into five personality types each one
received targeted advertising in return
for money Facebook provides such data to
all kinds of customers including
political interest groups during the
brexit campaign people in the fishing
industry who felt disadvantaged by EU
regulations were specifically targeted
on Facebook and to great effect but
unlike its users Facebook itself is not
at all transparent who is influencing
whom and for how much money is not known
and the website says it's largely not
responsible for the content of posts
executives are focused on growing the
company instead Facebook has been on a
shopping spree further consolidating its
dominant position on the digital market
it's now the fifth most valuable brand
in the world
so Alex Facebook is making more and more
money as we learn there but is it
getting quicker at tackling this problem
with fake news first of all I can't
speak for Facebook but I know that the
European Union initiated monitoring and
the numbers they're visual they're
getting better the social media company
is getting better in deleting the fake
news or hate speech stuff but I think of
course it's always a way to go to
improve your processes what why are they
getting better is is the fines that they
could be hit with I don't think that
this is the motivation of their work
right now because right now the
situation is okay they are responsible
for the content if they know that there
is illegal content on their website but
it's a learning process
it's a cooperation process between the
police between companies between
associations or complaint officers like
us and you always learn more and more
and then if both sides getting better
than the results getting better it just
briefly our fines effective do you think
not in my way there there's like
millions of euros not in the way they
are discussed in Germany because I think
this is something you just push
companies to delete content and if you
delete content the hate is not done or
the fake news is not gone but the
freedom of speech is in danger then when
is everybody going to wake up and
realise do you think that the content
they're putting out there is up for sale
and it's not really private at all
despite their privacy settings the
internet technology is an open
technology so we really need to get the
people educated to understand what
technology they're using and what is
behind this technology if you're just
using it this is something I think we
need to get into schools very early so
if you know what you're doing and what
are the processes behind then you know
what is the potential may be
and what you told me selling your
information and because if I'm able to
understand what is happening behind the
website then I'm able to decide if I
want this the kids or adults no matter
what age we can basically kiss privacy
goodbye well I don't think so but I
think we really need to do something to
sensitive to people they reading it get
to know what they're doing this is
important Alex I hope everyone's
listening in I certainly am thank you
very much for coming in today thank you